il est le plus grand sein de six dents
il est l'apôtre de la gaule ils
commandent aux animaux
[Musique]
il commande au feu il commanda la
tempête et même à la mort
il a une vision de la fin du monde
[Musique]
rien qu'en france
500 communes et quatre mille églises
porte son nom c'est sous son aura
tutélaire que le grand roi des francs
clovis se convertira au catholicisme
saint martin est l'une des plus grandes
figures de la civilisation européenne
[Musique]
saint martin n'a pas laissé d'écrit
personnel il appartient à ces puissants
homme d'esprit de l'antiquité qui ont
façonné l'histoire par la seule force de
la parole et des actes
tel socrate connu grâce à platon
tel jésus connu grâce aux évangélistes
martin nous est connue par les écrits de
sulpice sévère sulpice sévère est le
premier auteur de souche gauloise ayant
écrit sur un sujet concernant la gaule
d'origine noble il était avocat à
bordeaux en 397 il écrit la vie de saint
martin qui fonde la littérature de notre
pays son livre obtient un vif succès
aussi en 404 il publie une suite à sa
biographie sous la forme d'un dialogue
qui réunit l'auteur et deux compagnons
posthume hien égale celui ci donnant son
nom à l' ouvrage aux côtés du littéraire
sulpice et du polémiste post-humain
galles va devenir le centre d'intérêt de
cette discussion sulpice le désigne
comme le disciple de saint martin c'est
pourquoi il invite à prendre la parole
pour ma part dit je suis d'avis qu'il
serait plus juste de demander cela à
galles
le fait est qu'il a beaucoup appris en
disciple qui ne peut ignorer les
exploits de son maître
invité à raconter ce qu'il a
personnellement appris de son intimité
avec martin galles hésite
[Musique]
pourquoi c'est qu'il ne maîtrise pas
très bien la langue latine et crue de ne
pas être compréhensible mais quand je
pense qu'un gaulois de souche comme moi
va parler entre deux aquitains je crains
que mon langage plus campagnard
n'offense vos oreilles trop urbaine
posthume il lui fait alors cette réponse
qui témoigne du bilinguisme latin
gaulois des trois amis et bien soit 10
posthume ya parlant celtique ou en
gaulois si tu préfères pourvu que tu
nous parles de martin
le nom de galles latinisé gallus
signifie d'ailleurs gaulois sulpice n'a
pas choisi au hasard d'appeler ainsi son
personnage principal
on est moins d'un siècle avant le
baptême de clovis et le récit oral des
exploits du plus grand syndicat sis dans
ce fait en gaulois de la gaule à la
france il n'y a en réalité qu'un pas
contrairement à une idée reçue la donne
n'est pas devenu romaine elle a traversé
l'empiré romain en conservant sa langue
et sa culture orale
de 300 à 500 de notre ère la
mondialisation latine se délite peu à
peu secoué par les migrations barbares
l'empiré romain s'effrite puis s'écroule
durant la même période émerge une
identité gaulois et catholique avec la
haute figure de saint martin
[Musique]
et ce sont des gens du peuple comme
galles qui ont diffusé la mémoire de
saint martin auprès des élites du clergé
[Musique]
le quatrième siècle et le grand
basculement du monde antique en deux ou
trois générations
l' empire romain passe du paganisme
d'état au christianisme d'état
c'est en 313 après sa victoire militaire
du conte milvius que l'empereur
constantin légalise le christianisme par
l'édit de milan
il met fin aux persécutions religieuses
et proclame la liberté de culte
constantin se convertit lui-même au
christianisme et promeut la paix de
l'église
mais l'époque est aux troubles religieux
des tensions permanentes agite la
puissance publique et un désarroi
spirituel gagne les masses populaires
pour pallier le désenchantement de
l'homme chaque groupe social tend vers
un idéal à son image dans l'armée
beaucoup de soldats voue un culte à
litres à un dieu d'origine perse que
l'on représente en train de poignarder
un taureau à en croire le savant ernest
renan peut s'en fallu que notre
continent
puis le reste du monde ne fissent ya le
dieu mithra
on peut dire que si le christianisme eut
été arrêté dans sa croissance par
quelques maladies mortelles
le monde utt me trilles afte
c'est plutôt dans les villes que le
christ a élu domicile
les premiers chrétiens sont souvent des
citadins aux côtés de jésus évitera les
populations de lempire vénère aussi les
déesse isis ou cybèle et des philosophes
stoïciens zwicky curien propage toutes
sortes de conception du monde qu'il
était loin le temps où romulus avait
pour la première fois invoqué jupiter
plus de mille ans après le règne de
constantin
on assiste à l'irrésistible montée en
puissance de la religion chrétienne
durant tout le quatrième siècle
malgré la tentative éphémère et sans
suite de l'empereur julien en 361 de
restaurer un culte païen au soleil
le christianisme devient dominant
mais il reste déchirée par des hérésies
alors en 380 l'empereur théodose met fin
au désordre spirituel par l'édit de
thessalonique
ils déclarent tous les peuples doivent
se rallier à la fois transmises aux
romains par l'apôtre pierre
c'est à dire la sainte trinité du père
du fils et du saint-esprit
ainsi la foi catholique devient telle la
religion officielle et obligatoire de l'
empire romain martin et vers 317 est
mort en 397 embrasse cet élan passionnel
du 4e siècle et va s'affirmer comme
l'apôtre de la gaule
c'était l'hiver en lan et 335 dans le
nord de la gaule un froid glacial pellet
la terre flocons et verglas recouvrait
la campagne devant les portes damien
retentissent et le bruit de la vie
urbaine
dans un coin un misérable presque nue
grelotter dans le froid intense il
mendiait avec une honte pudique qui
confine à la grâce
cette humilité silencieuse et mutin
cavaliers qui s'en venait le jeune
soldat n'avait sur lui que son manteau
une pièce de laine comme une cape que
l'on accroche à l'épaule par une fibule
donné la cape ne rien donner
martin tranche la question il ôte sa
cape et de son épée la déchire en deux
parties égales
ils gardent l'une pour lui et offre
l'autre aux mendiants
puis il poursuit son chemin sans un mot
mais qui est ce mendiant
[Musique]
à la nuit tombée martin fait un songe
il renvoie le mondiaux auxquels il vient
de donner la moitié de sa cape et ce
mendiant
c'est le christ en personne un jour
qu'il n'avait sur lui que ces armes est
un simple manteau de soldats au milieu
d'un hiver qui plus âpre que de coutume
faisait à tel point grelotter que par la
violence du froid il avait ôté la vie à
beaucoup
martin rencontre à la porte de la cité
damien un pauvre nu celui-ci priait les
passants d'avoir pitié de lui mais aucun
d'eux ne faisait cas du misérable aussi
saisissant l'épée qu'il portait à la
ceinture
il partage sa clinique par le milieu en
donne un morceau aux pauvres et ce
rabais avec le reste
la nuit suivante après qu'il se fut
abandonnée au sommeil il vu le christ
vêtus de la partie de la chlamydia dont
il a découvert le pauvre dans cette
vision onirique
jésus lui fait signe de s'approcher et
le présente ainsi aux anges c'est martin
encore catéchumènes qui m'a couvert de
ce vêtement
dès son réveil frappé par la grâce
céleste martin cours recevoir le baptême
sa grande âme n'a que 18 ans
cette double scène est connue sous le
nom de charité et songe de saint martin
la cape de saint martin aux roms
histoire venere com reliques sous la
monarchie
elle sera entreposé dans une pièce
sacrée cette pièce en référence à la
cape prendra le nom de chapelle
synonyme aujourd'hui l'église la
chapelle était à l'origine l'espace où
reposer la sainte cap du soldat martin
martin à 44 ans quand il quitte l'armée
[Musique]
sentant l'appel de la vocation il décide
de rentrer dans les ordres
l'évêque de poitiers saint-hilaire
intronise alors martin comme prêtre
exorciste martin le soldat de l'armée
terrestre devient soldats de dieu
l'épée sera sa prière l'ennemi les
démons et les idoles martin s'installe
sur les bords boisé de la loire là il
mène une vie d'ermite se nourrissant de
racines et de plantes
la nuit il dort sur son silice posés à
même le sol dans ce paisible exil il se
voue à la prière et à la contemplation
divine loin des agitations du siècle si
proche des silencieuses grandeur de
l'éternel
sa vie intérieure était si intense qu'il
s'entretenait familièrement avec des
anges
il est même avéré que des anges lui
apparut au souvent c'est bien qu'il
conversait hâtivement avec lui mille ans
plus tard jeanne d'arc ne dira pas autre
chose de ses célèbres voit rapidement la
vertu de martin se répand à travers les
régions
on vient de loin le consulter et de
nombreux disciples le rejoigne dans les
années 360
martin fondent à ligugé dans la vienne
le premier monastère de gaulle
la victoire sur la mort est sans doute
le plus grand miracle qu'un homme puisse
accomplir sur terre martin venait juste
de fonder le monastère de ligugé
[Musique]
à côté de la vie contemplative il
s'occupait aussi d'enseigner le
catéchisme aux païens qui désiraient se
convertir
or un jour il advint qu'un catéchumènes
tomba gravement malade avant d'avoir pu
recevoir le baptême il me il fait alors
ce que l'on désigne de nos jours par
l'acronyme le fmi pour expérience de
mort imminente selon les nombreux
témoignages lors d'une amie l'homme sort
du corps traversé un tunnel sombre et
vol en direction d'une lumière divine et
apaisante
souvent elle y rencontre son ange
gardien
elle revoit le film de sa vie passée et
elle en fait le bilan
[Musique]
certains rapportent avoir aussi visiter
un jardin idyllique où parcouru une
ville à la majesté sans pareil
les valeurs de ce monde spirituel sont
l'amour et le savoir tous nos actes
toutes nos pensées sur terre
interagissent en permanence avec l'au
delà
mais il ya aussi des emmy négative
l'âme damnée plongé alors dans une
noirceur horrible est harcelé par des
démons tortionnaires que l'expérience
soit positive ou négative
on ignore ce qui attend la mpt passer ce
seuil l'ultime
après ce bref contact l'âme est donc
renvoyée sur terre et y avait intègre
son corps le témoignage du païen fait
référence à plusieurs étapes d'une heure
et demie
il avait d'ailleurs coutume de raconter
qu'il s'était dépouillé de son corps
pour être conduit au tribunal du juge
qu'il avait reçu la triste sentence être
destiné aux lieux obscurs et à la foule
vulgaire alors deux ans j'avais exposé
aux juges qu'il était l'homme pour qui
priaient martin d'où les mêmes dangereux
sur tordre de le ramener de le rendre à
martin et de le restituer à sa vie
antérieure
deux heures passent seul avec le défunt
martin est en prière quand soudain le
morts ressuscitent
les deux anges on rapportait le
catéchumène à la vie terrestre
ce miracle est le premier à avoir
rapporté la renommée à saint martin
l'abbé réalise d'autres résurrection peu
après ils ramènent à la vie un jeune
homme qui s'était pendu plus tard près
de chartres hilweh suscite le tout jeune
enfant qu'une mère venait de perdre
la grâce divine canalise une forme
d'énergie plus forte que la mort
[Musique]
sa renommée prend une telle ampleur que
le cad juillet 371 sur insistance de la
population locale marta est élevé au
rang d'évêque de tours et les disciples
affluent de plus en plus alors en 372
près de tours
martin fonde l'abbaye de marmoutier
le monastère
arc bouté dans la falaise rocheuse
abrite environ 80 moines les cellules de
ces moines sont des cabanes en bois ou
plus souvent des chambres troglodytes
creusé à même la falaise
tous ces ermites même ceux issus des
rangs de la noblesse se vêtent avec
humilité quelques-uns se livrent au
labeur de copiste
[Musique]
beaucoup même surtout une vie de messes
et de prières
avec les siècle l'abbaye de marmoutier
apparaît comme une pépinière de grâce au
coeur de la gaule renaissante désormais
la baie saint martin va concilier vie de
moine responsabilités d'évêque
un lieu sacré nécessite parfois un
nettoyage spirituel près de marmoutier
était honoré la tombe d'un soi-disant
martyrs perplexe martin avec ces moines
se rend sur les lieux pour vérification
là avec l'aide de dieu
l'abbé convoque en public larmes du
défunt le fantôme lui apparaît et
confesse de vive voix n'avoir été qu'une
ville fripouille de son vivant debout
devant la tombe il pria le seigneur de
mai montre et celui qui était enterrée
et sa qualité puis s'étant tourné à
gauche il voit près de lui seul vers une
ombre salle et sauvage
elle avait été un voleur exécuté pour
son crime et que le vulgaire célébré par
erreur chose étonnante ce qui était
présent entendez la voix du fantôme sans
pour autant le voir l'abbé fit aussitôt
retiré l'hôtel du faux martyr délivrant
ainsi le peuple d'une superstition
ses contemporains décrivent martin comme
un personnage excentrique avec une
chevelure hirsute et des habits négligé
à la fois passionné et mètres de lui
solitaire et illustre martin rayonne
d'une aura quasi surnaturelle
jamais personne ne l'avait en colère ni
ému ni infligé ni en train de rire
toujours égal à lui même le visage
rayonnant d'une loi pourra séduire
select
il avait l'air étranger à la nature
humaine mettant d'excellence suscite la
jalousie car la hiérarchie de l'église
voit martin d'un mauvais oeil
engoncé dans ses habits fastueux le haut
clergé s'indigne et mehdi de ce
mystérieux personnage
et même aux douloureuses et déplorable
impiété on rapportait que ses
persécuteurs quoique peu nombreux
n'étaient autres que des évêques paysans
et gens du peuple
au contraire font fi des remontrances du
clergé mondain et savent gré de la vertu
authentique de martin d'autant plus
malheureux et notre pays qu ayant
possédé un si grand homme près de lui
n'a pas mérité de le connaître
à cette accusation je ne met toutefois
pas les gens du peuple
seuls les clairs seuls les prêtres
l'ignorent ce n'est pas sans injustice
que les envieux ne veulent pas le
connaître
car s'il avait connu ses vertus il
aurait dû reconnaître leurs vices
persécuté par des évêques hors sol
martin force l'admiration de la masse
encore polythéistes qui la mène à dieu
et à la sainte trinité
tel un druide enseignants la parole du
christ martin fait la synthèse entre
deux mondes
la gaule profonde et l'évangile
d'où l'immense succès de ce héros
métaphysique incarnation spirituelle du
pays réel
[Musique]
la forêt est le premier sanctuaire des
dieux
l'arbre atypique a toujours exercé une
puissante fascination reflétant par sa
physionomie la beauté majestueuse les
tourments de l'âme
l'impassible éternité
dans un village se dressait un vieux
sanctuaire et un pain gigantesque source
de superstition martin voulait
christianisé les lieux et y bâtir une
église
accompagné de ses moines l'abbé fait
démolir le temps puis ils cherchent à
s'attaquer à l'arbre mais des païens
s'opposent à ce projet alors les
polythéistes l'ensta lab est un défi ils
lui disent puisque tu attends confiance
en ton christ place toi donc sous les
branches de cet arbre
nous couvrons nous même le pain qu'as tu
à craindre si ton dieu est si puissant
qui en ressortira sauf martin accepte
comme le pain était incliné les
polythéistes demande d'un martin de se
placer du côté où devraient tomber
l'arbre que se tenant sur l'autre flanc
c'est le coeur léger que les bûcherons
commence à fendre la souche séculaire de
leur idole
bientôt le pain chancel le bois craque
le tronc commencé chez l'homme de dieu
lève alors son bras au devant de l'arbre
il fait le signe de croix
aussi tant le géant vert comme porté par
le souffle d'un vent contraire inverse
sa course
les adorateurs de la nature voient leur
arbre fétiche fondre sur eux
le pain dans sa chute avait déjà fait
entendre un craquement
déjà il tombait des jeunes s'abattait
sur lui quand martin élève sam à la
rencontre de l'abbé lui oppose le signe
du salut mais alors on eut cru l'arbre
repousser en arrière par une sorte
d'ouragan hills a bâti du côté opposé de
sorte qu'il fallait écraser les paysans
qui s'était tenue en lieu sûr
les moines à courre joyeux auprès de
leurs habits
quant aux polythéistes frappés dans leur
âme par le miracle oeuvre saisissante du
vrai dieu
il demande un martin le baptême l'évêque
les baptise et reconstruit
là où gît le pain ça crée une église
cette destruction d'un arbre sacré est
le signe de la fin des temps et l'aube
d'une ère nouvelle
vers l'an 800 après sa victoire sur les
tribus saxon l'empereur charlemagne
reproduira le rituel martinien en
faisant abattre lire mines sur l'arbre
sacré des polythéistes de saxe
selon un ancien vite les paysans gaulois
un billet de blanc les statues de dieux
païens puis organisait des processions à
travers champs pour favoriser les
récoltes selon une coutume on recouvrait
nawal blanc des statues de dieux païens
et pitoyable folie les gaulois des
campagnes leur faisais faire le tour de
leur champ or un jour martin vitaux loin
passer un cortège de ce genre
alors bien que distant de 500 pas il
immobilise d'un simple s'il decroix
toute la procession le vent le signe de
croix vers elle il ordonne à la foux de
ne plus bouger de déposer ce qu'elle
porte alors choses miraculeuses
on vit d'abord les malheureux se figer
comme des rock puis dans un ultime élan
comme il s'efforçait de marché sans y
parvenir il se met à tourner en à
tourbillon ridicule jusqu'à ce que
vaincue il dépose de poids du corps en
réalité le corps portait était un mort
et nous on est à tu il s'agissait
d'obsèques et non d'un rituel invoqua
thouars à l'adresse des anciens dieux
martin laissa donc repartir le cortège
ainsi les forces at-il à s'arrêter quand
il le voulu et leurs familles t-il de
s'en aller quand il lui plus
une autre fois un chariot du fisc
escorté de légionnaires avançait sur la
route
ce qu'on voit peu et meubles imposé
crainte et respect aux badauds
mais en passant juste devant martin les
mules harnachés sont tout à coup saisi
d'effroi
en réponse des miliciens se ruent sur
martin et le rouent de coups
survient alors un étrange incident
au moment de repartir les cochers ont
beau claquer le fouet les chevaux
demeure immobile comme des statues
pendant ce temps revenu à leurs chariots
et assouvi de rage il ordonne qu'on
pousse les mules à poursuivre leur route
mais tout se raidir fixés au sol tels
des statues de bronze malgré les cris
répétés des charretiers et les
claquements tous azimuts et fouet et
elle ne bougeait absolument pas horrifié
les légionnaires s'enquiert de
l'identité de celui qu'ils viennent de
molester dès qu'ils apprennent que celle
illustre saint martin il se jette à ses
pieds et le supplie de leur pardonner
miséricordieux l'abbé les apps août avec
bienveillance
les mules pu remarcher à nouveau et les
impôts s'éloignèrent en fait tout le
règne animal obéit à saint martin une
vache s'était écarté de son troupeau et
attaquer les hommes de ses cornes la
bête furieuse cours et droits sur martin
impavide l'abbé lève son bras et ordonne
l'invalidation se fiche dans le sol
apercevant le démon qui agitent la vache
l'abbé l'exercice de ces paroles
créatures maléfiques cesse de harceler
cet animal innocent aussitôt le démon
disparaît et la génisse délivré vient se
prosterner aux pieds de l'évêque
toujours dans les champs des chiens pour
chasser un lièvre
pris de pitié martin commandes aux
limiers de s'immobiliser et le lièvre
s'enfuit sains et saufs
un jour le maître marcher au bord de la
loire en compagnie d'une nuée de
disciples tout à coup on voit des
oiseaux piqué dans les eaux du fleuve
pour attraper des poissons montrant la
scène aux élèves
martin et non cette parabole les démons
sont comme des oiseaux plongeurs ils
capturent les âmes imprudente pour les
dévorer alors le saint lô redonne aux
volatiles de s'envoler à l'instant les
créatures à pul se regroupent en nuées
et s'échappe des flots vers les collines
boisées preuve de la supériorité de dieu
sur la force sournoise du démon dans un
village les païens fréquentait un temple
très ancien et de grande renommée
loin du druidisme originel ces rituels
vide de substance tournait souvent à la
superstition voulons évangéliser les
campagnes et les débarrasser de
l'idolâtrie fusent par la force
martin gagne ce village et incendient le
temple mais le vent tournant véhémence
bientôt des boules de feu se forment des
rafales enflammé jaillissent hors du
sanctuaire et menace d'embraser la
maison mitoyenne au temple alors martin
non sur le toit de la maison et face au
vent des signes de sa main le signe de
croix
aussitôt contre toute logique le feu
s'éloigne mais alors miracles ont vu le
feu se retourner contre les rafales à
l'instar d'un conflit entre les éléments
en lutte
ainsi par la puissance de martin le feu
n'agit que là où il en a reçu l'ordre
on retrouve cette maîtrise du feu dans
d'autres scènes un hiver martin faisait
halte pour la nuit dans la sacristie
d'une église l'éclair lui avait préparé
un feu de cheminée et une couche de
paille
or le singer l'habitude de dormir à même
le sol
aussi au moment de se coucher il envoie
balader la paillasse et s'endort mais
dans la nuit quelques étincelles
s'échappe de la cheminée et enflamme la
paille sèche rapidement un incendie se
propage martin s'éveille
il se précipite vers la porte mais
tandis qu'il lutte avec le verrou le feu
le rattrape piégée il se croit perdu
alors le saint homme place son salut non
dans la fuite mais en dieu ils se
mettent en prière et le miracle survient
mais alors la volonté de dieu écartant
le feu martha prix y est intacte au
milieu du cercle de flammes après que
les moines ont forcé les portes de
l'extérieur il voit l'évêque indemme et
l'extrait de la braise saint-martin
analyse ainsi sa mésaventure au fond le
feu sévit autour de moi aussi longtemps
que l'esprit troublé je tentais de
sortir en brisant la porte mais dès que
je sollicite l étendard de la croix et
les armes de la prière les flammes
proches oculaire et me faire l'effet
d'une rose et elles dont j'avais éprouvé
la malle brûlures
une scène quasi bouffonne relate aussi
la rencontre de martin avec l'empereur
valentinien premier une rencontre sous
haute tension
car les deux hommes ne s'aimait guerre
valentine et recevez le saint dans son
palais martin se tenait debout et contre
toute courtoisie l'empereur demeurait à
6 plein de morgue
l'orgueil c'est a refusé de se lever et
garder les fesses vissé sur son trône
jusqu'à ce que le trône royal fait
couvert d'un feu et que l' incendie
souffla le roi dans la partie du corps
sur laquelle il siégeait ainsi
l'orgueilleux est expulsé de son trône
et malgré lui se lève devant martin
martin déclenché le feu ou repousse le
feu à sa guise
à amboise en touraine s'élevait un
ancien château transformé depuis en
monastère le donjon culminé à une
hauteur formidable et finissait en cône
les pailles elle adorait comme une idole
aux dires du prêtre des lieux l'ouvragé
taissy imposant que même en faisant
appel à l'armée
il eût été impossible de le déraciner
[Musique]
alors un soir martin s'installe au pied
de ce château maudit en prière il égrène
les heures toute la nuit
le lendemain un effroyable orages
détruit la tour j'ai dans le village
d'amboise c'est-à-dire au vieux château
habité maintenant par nos frères
vous connaissez un sanctuaire bâti en
gros oeuvre en pierre de taille se
dressait une tour massive qui communique
à son sommet entretenez la superstition
local partenité extérieur alors martin
recourant à ces illustres ressources
veille en prière toute la nuit au matin
une tempête se lève et renverse
sanctuaire de l'idole jusqu'à ses
fondations
un monument similaire fut détruit de la
même façon par la prière
martin déclenché une sorte de tempête le
texte parle d'une colonne céleste peut
être un cyclone qui s'abat sur la
colonne ou et tisser une statue payet
tout fut anéantie il se préparait à
renverser une colonne à la masse énorme
surmonté d'une idole
selon son habitude il se tourne à la
prière il est certain que l'on vit se
précipiter du ciel une colonne quasi
identique qui en impactant l'idole
réduisit en poussière toute cette masse
inexpugnable saint martin reste lié à la
tempête même après sa mort au 6e siècle
grégoire de tours raconte dans sa
chronique un événement étonnant survenu
dans la forêt de soissons
[Musique]
dans le royaume des francs la guerre
sévit c'est entre les divers descendons
de clovis
clotaire premier retrancher derrière des
abattis d'arbres se protéger de l'assaut
est imminent de childebert et ibères
la reine mère clotilde rester au
monastère de tours prier saint martin de
faire cesser cette guerre fratricide
entre ses fils et petit-fils alors une
tempête se lève
des rafales phénoménal palais le camp
des assaillants comprenant qu'ils ont
offensé dieu childebert et tibère
demande pardon et font la paix avec
clotaire aussitôt la tempête se calme
curieusement juste en face dans le camp
de clotaire ilnu dit on aucun orage a
déploré
tandis que childebert et hiver l'acier
jette avec leurs armes et manigances ans
de le tuer le jour suivant une tempête
se leva au matin au lieu où ils
s'étaient rassemblés qui déchire
allaitantes arracha les affaires et
renverse à tous la foudre mais les de
tonnerre et de pierre s'abattit sur eux
il fait pénitence et demandèrent pardon
à dieu d'avoir voulu agir contre leur
propre sang quant à clotaire aucune
goutte depuis le tomba sur lui on
entendit par le bruit du tonnerre et nul
souffle de vent ne se fit sentir alors
les autres dépêcha des messagers pour
solliciter la paix et l'amitié
c'est chose faite en revanche chez soi
ce dont nul ne doute c'est que la
puissance de saint-martin fonds obtenus
à la demande de la reine
deux siècles séparent grégoire de tours
de sulpice sévère pourtant au fil des
générations les attributs de saint
martin n'ont pas changé son attitude
miraculeuse à modifier le climat peut
aussi avoir des incidences sur les
récoltes
la région de sens dans l'yonne subissait
chaque année un terrible orage de grêle
comme s'il y avait un micro climat
dépressif vers 377 martin 20 mettre fin
aux orages annuel l'effet bénéfique de
sa prière durera exactement 20 ans
jusqu'à la mort du sein aussitôt après
la tempête ressuscita ayant prié la
martin libera à ce point la région
entière de l'assaut de ce fléau que
pendant les vingt ans où il vécut
personne dans ce pays n'est plus à
supporter la grêle mais l'année de son
décès d'une tempête revigoré ci a bâti
le nouveau cette capacité supposée de
certains humains a commandé aux tempêtes
et à agir sur les récoltes restera
vivace au cours du haut moyen-âge
sintas gaubert était évêque de lyon au
début du neuvième siècle dans son traité
de la grêle et des tempêtes agobert
rapporte des faits survenus sous
charlemagne
selon les rumeurs des sorciers s'étaient
rendus maîtres de la météo et par leur
magie noire était en mesure de
déclencher la tempête
d'où leur nom de tempestaire or
l'opinion publique les accusaient
notamment de faire usage de la grêle
pour renverser les céréales dans les
champs et de causer ainsi la ruine des
paysans
ce n'est pas tout
une fois le champ dévasté des aéronefs
descendait des nuages pour prendre le
blé et le rapporter chez eux
ces mystérieuses créatures de l'espace
habité le lointain pays de magoni on
accusait donc les tempes esther
d'ici-bas de faire commerce de céréales
avec les extraterrestres de la céleste
magoni
nous en avons vu et entendu beaucoup
enseveli sous une telle démence aline
est dans une telle sottise qu'il croit
t10 qu'il existe un pays qu'on appelle
la magoni d'où viennent les nuages des
nefs dans lesquelles les récoltes tomber
sous la grêle est détruite par les
tempêtes sont transportés vers ce pays
c'est aéronautes ayant donné le prix aux
tempes esther et en ayant reçu le blé et
d'autres récoltes
serra veulent agricoles ne sont pas sans
écho avec des énigmes de notre époque
que penser par exemple de ces
agroglyphes ou cercles de culture qui
surgissent parfois dans nos champs de
blé à l'insu de tous même dans des lieux
très surveillé ce phénomène commence à
être connue sont pour autant trouver une
explication définitive les céréales
fléchi et couché au sol des signes
d'étranges figures géométriques visible
seulement du siège
le mystère s'épaissit quand on constate
que les bords de ces figures sont précis
sans bavure ni reprises qu'il n'ya au
sol ni traces de roues ni même traces de
pas boussoles et objets électroniques
tels les portables sont perturbées par
le champ magnétique dans la grande ligue
les tiges des céréales qui ont été
soumises à analyses révèlent des noeuds
beaucoup plus dilatés qu'à la normale
et comme gonflé de l'intérieur par une
chaleur foudroyante
certaines de ces figures exclu la
possibilité de simple canular et
présente une telle complexité
mathématiques et techniques que savant
et militaires restent sans réponse
[Musique]
y at il une explication humaine à toutes
ces figures ou bien sont elle façonné
par d'autres intelligences créatures de
l'espace voyageurs du temps anges et
démons qui comment et pourquoi
un jour la population médiévale exulte
et pense avoir trouvé la réponse
on vient de capturer quatre extra
terrestre qui aurait chuté de leurs
engins volants après enquête
lévesque a gobard démontre toutefois
l'innocence de ces quatre véritables
humains
nous en avons vu plusieurs dans une
assemblée exhibé quatre individus ligoté
trois hommes et une femme qui serait
comme tombé de senneff ces détenus
ligotés pendant quelques jours on finit
donc par les exhiber dans une assemblée
comme j'ai dit en ma présence afin de
les lapider mais après moult
raisonnement la vérité ayant vaincu
c'est ceux là même qui les avait exhibé
qui furent comme disait prophétie
confondues comme on confond le volant
quand il est attrapé au delà du mystère
qui enveloppe cette anecdote on peut
s'interroger sur le nom de la magoni en
longues gauloise magos signifie plein
champ et le suffixe n'y a peut
correspondre à une divinisation comme
epos cheval donne epona la jument divine
magos plein champ ferait deux magots
n'ya la plaine divine
or aux dires du témoignage médiévale
c'est bien pour le compte d'une plaine
céleste magoni que des plaines terrestre
aurait été pillée par des aéronautes
[Musique]
y aurait-il dans cette aventure
lyonnaise une réminiscence d'anciennes
traditions celtiques
toujours est il que fort de son
témoignage d'engins spatiaux entrer en
contact avec la terre le premier du
genre dans l'occident chrétien à gobain
avait devenu depuis le saint patron des
ufologues aux chasseurs de vie
quant à saint-martin son commandement
sur la tempête semble avoir inspiré les
ambigu tempestaire
il y à un mystère quant à l'origine du
signe de croix l'évangile reste muet à
ce sujet d'après la mémoire écrite
le christ ne l'a publiquement jamais
enseigné
même après sa résurrection dans ce geste
quaternaire on appose la main sur le
front puis le plexus
enfin les épaule gauche et droite on
l'accomplît au nom du père du fils et du
saint-esprit
or le signe de croix est la principale
action de martin lorsqu'il veut
accomplir un miracle puissant repoussoir
contre le mal le st l'emploi à maintes
reprises et toujours avec succès
d'autres gestes sont utilisés par martin
le gouverneur régional aliciens était un
despote un jour que les deux hommes
s'entretenait martin souffla en
direction du démon perché sur le dos du
gouverneur ce à quoi le gouverneur ne
s'attendait pas quand il fut entré dans
la salle martin vie assis derrière le
dos d'avis siens un des murs d'une
taille gigantesque de loin il lui
souffla dessus avis siens croyant que
c'était sur lui qu'il avait soufflé puis
demande à saint homme pourquoi me traite
u16 alors martin dit non ce n'est pas
sur toi mais sur l'afrique est appuyée
sur la nuque le diable sans parti et
abandonna son siège familier suite au
souffle purificateur de saint martin le
gouverneur un vice
devin plus doux avec autrui
à chartres une petite fille de 12 ans
étaient muettes de naissance son père se
présenta alors à martin pour qu'il la
guérisse après avoir béni quelques
gouttes d'huile martin ouvre la bouche
de la fillette il en plaques la langue
avec ses doigts et y répandre l'huile
sacré aussitôt parlant pour la première
fois la fillette prononce le nom de son
père en un seule présence des évêques et
du père de la fillette
il se couche en prière selon son
habitude puis d'une formule d'exorciste
il bénit à peu d'huile et verse l'a
senti fientes liqueur dans la bouche de
la fillette
tout en lui tenant la langue de ses
doigts et le miracle ne sut pas le sein
il lui demande le nom de son père
aussitôt la fillette répond
quand une entité surnaturelle s'empare
d'un corps et se l'approprient pour en
user à sa guise
on appelle cela une possession le
posséder est souvent un être humain pris
d'une sorte de folie sans explication
logique ils tremblent
il pleure il est vide il grogne comme
une bête ou bien s'exprime dans une
langue normalement inconnu de lui
parfois tel un voyant extra lucide il
dévoile des secrets
dans les cas les plus spectaculaires
sa force physique dépasse de beaucoup
ses capacités musculaires la possession
touche aussi les animaux comme on a vu
avec une vache folle voire un objet tel
une maison hantée
l'exorcisme encouragé par l'église
consiste à combattre les possessions
démoniaques le christ lui-même a exhorté
ses prêtres à chasser le mal
guérissent et les malades ressusciter
les morts purifier les lépreux expulser
les démons
la lutte oppose non pas le prêtre au
posséder mais dieu au diable
c'est à dire deux énergies surnaturel
celle de l'amour forces et celles du mal
destructeur
en théologie on donne le nom
d'énergumènes à la personne possédée par
le diable
un jour que martin marche
incognito vers une église des
énergumènes présent dans cette église
font soudain entendre des cris les
posséder son soulevé du sol et levitte
le monastère du bienheureux était à 2002
la cité mais combien de fois quand il
portait sont pas hors du seuil de sa
cellule pour venir à l'église on voyait
dans toute l'église des énergumènes
rugissants et les troupes à d'années
comme tremblay à l'arrivée de leurs
juges
si bien que les plaintes des démos
indiqué au clair la venue de l'évêque
alors que leclerc n'en savais rien je
vise à posséder kiala proche de martin
fut emporté en l'air suspendu les bras
tendus en eau en sorte que de ses pieds
il ne touchait plus du tout le sol une
fois dans l'église
martin ordonne à la foule de sortir pour
demeurer seul avec les posséder la drapé
dans son manteau il commence à prier et
chasse les démons hors des corps ayant
fait approcher des énergumènes ils en
venaient aux autres de s'en aller et
après avoir verrouillé les portes c'est
au milieu de l'église
enveloppé de son silice et aspergée de
cendres qu'il priait prosterner au sol
alors on voyait vraiment les misérables
expulsé par divers orifices les a
emportés en eau par les pieds comme
suspendue à un nuage
ailleurs on envoyait qui sans être
soumis à la question confessé leur crime
sans qu'on le leur demande
il révéler leur nom la sape les jupiter
l'autre mercure délivrer de ces
invisibles vampires
les victimes pourront reprendre une vie
sereine
face à une guérison miraculeuse la
science matériel a servi à l'apparence
ne peut évidemment fournir aucune
réponse objective don gratuit de dieu
l'énergie surnaturel est une réalité
pourtant observable que seuls seraient
peut être en mesure de comprendre un
savoir global synthèse entre médecine et
perceptions du sacré certains grands
savants des temps modernes ont eu
l'intuition d'ouvrir la porte de
l'inconnu le docteur alexis carrel prix
nobel de médecine 1912 sera le témoin
direct d'un miracle à lourdes ce qui
l'amène à admettre l'existence d'un
pouvoir de l'esprit sur la matière
d'où son postulat quant à la force
mystérieuse mais bien réelle de la
prière le miracle caractérisée surtout
par une accélération extrême des
processus de guérison organique
la seule condition indispensable au
phénomène et la prière mais il n'est pas
besoin que le malade lui-même pris ou
qu'ils possèdent la foi religieuse
il suffit que quelques après de lui soit
en état de prière de tels faits sont
d'une haute signification
il montre la réalité de certaines
relations de nature encore inconnue
entre les processus psychologique et
organique
[Musique]
de nos jours rien qu'à lourdes 70
guérisons ont été authentifiés
combien de fois martin at-il expulsés de
mauvais esprit difficile à dire mais la
mémoire orale transcrite par sulpice
sévère s'est plu à en regrouper trois en
une sorte de trilogie
curieusement ces trois exorcisme
s'articule autour des trois fonctions
indo-européenne les trois fonctions indo
européennes sont une structure
idéologique hérité des temps
préhistoriques que l'on retrouve sur un
vaste espace culturel en europe et en
asie en france elles sont restées
célèbres dans l'organisation sociale
sous la royauté
selon trois ordres le clergé la noblesse
et le tiers état plus globalement les
trois fonctions gouvernent
respectivement le sacré la guerre et la
production
d'abord un païen aisée du nom de tetra
ben avait un esclave fois lié à l'or il
demande à martin de guérir le malheureux
l'abîmé tuiles conditions
que tes trad se fasse baptisé tetra
d'accept martin impose ses paumes sur
l'esclave ligoté et le délivre de
l'esprit mal ensuite martin se trouvait
dans la villa d'un notable quand le
cuisinier pris de folie se met à mordre
tout le monde allant au contact
martin introduit ses doigts dans la
bouche du procédé et lui dit si tu as
quelques pouvoir dévorer les vaincus le
démon s'échappe en diarrhée
enfin selon une rumeur des envahisseurs
barbares s'approchait de la cité mais
avant que la panique ne gagne la foule
martin interroge un peu cédé 10 mois si
cette nouvelle est vraie
le démo avoua que c'était lui et dix
autres démons qui avait répandu cette
rumeur parmi les publics afin que cette
crainte face à thau - martin de ce
village
ainsi saint martin aura réalisés
successivement trois actes précis il
obtient la conversion de thé trad en
guérissant son esclave
ce qui lie cet exorcisme à la fonction
sacrée il libère du démon un cuisinier
productive et il démasque la fausse
rumeur d'une invasion ce qui lie cet
exorcisme à la fonction guerrière
à travers cette trilogie d'exorcisme
les trois fonctions indo-européenne
sacré guerre production sont
parfaitement représentée
les entités démoniaques ne rendent pas
seulement les hommes fous elle les rend
aussi méchant brice était un prêtre
recueilli jadis comme enfants pauvres
par martin il avait grandi à l'abbaye de
marmoutier
mais le temps avait vicié son arme
happé par le monde il s'adonnait aux
plaisirs matériels tel un prince
séculier brice s'était ainsi constitué
un haras et une cour de beaux esclaves
pourquoi lui qui n'avait jamais rien
posséder avant d'entrer dans les ordres
elle va t'il des chevaux et acquérez
t-il des esclaves
en ce temps là beaucoup l'accusé d'avoir
accumulé non seulement de jeunes
barbares mais aussi des demoiselles aux
traits fins un jour martin le ser mona
pour cette conduite indigne d'un homme
de dieu sur le moment le mauvais prêtre
ne dit mot mais le lendemain deux
entités infernale se perche sur une
haute roche près de l'abbaye
là elle guette brise dont le craindre
sas les apr reproche en d'interminables
ronde
brice enfle maintenant de fureur ils se
ruent à grandes enjambées devant martin
et l'invectivé la haine reid est
tellement son visage qu'il en serait
presque arrivés aux mains en face martin
conservait sang froid et bienveillance
car il avait vu les deux gargouille
s'emparer du malheureux la colère
assouvi brice s'en retourne et s'éloigne
du monastère et les deux démons
s'échappe comme réveiller d'un cauchemar
brice comprend soudain ce qu'il vient de
faire alors il regagne l'abbaye et se
jette au genou de son maître rongé de
remords il implore son pardon plein de
compassion saint-martin absout le pauvre
homme
pour martin ce n'était pas une peine
difficile que de pardonner aux suppliant
alors à celui ci est à nous tous
le ca raconta comment il avait vu les
démons harceler brice martin ne
s'émouvait pas des injures calais plus
nui à celui qui les avait répandu
saint-brice fut si bien pardonner qu'il
a sa fête le 13 novembre
il est devenu le saint patron des juges
et saint martin de conclure sur cette
affaire si le christ à supporter judas
pourquoi moi ne supporterait pas brice
les moeurs de saint-martin et est chaste
on ne lui connaît aucune femme et il fit
l'éloge de la virginité à travers une
parabole
un cru avaient été divisés par les
paysans en trois parties un tiers était
brouter par des bovins la prairie
présentait sa verdure propre et monotone
un tiers était voué au port la terre
tout retourné et dévasté exhibait une
fange dégoûtante
un tiers était restée intacte là le au
manteau d'herbe 7 est revêtu de fleurs
de toutes les couleurs
chaque tiers offre une image précise
d'un des trois états de la vie sociale
là où abondent les fleurs c'est le prix
le plus beau les pétales multicolores
hisse ainsi comme des gemmes beauté
digne de dieu c'est le précieux fruit de
la virginité
[Musique]
là où paissent les bovins le prêt a été
défloré
privé de pétales le paysage offre moins
de majesté mais l'herbe monochromie est
encore belle c'est le noble résultats du
mariage
[Musique]
enfin là où pataugent les ports le prêt
n'est plus qu'une masse de boue le
soulier nu est ravagé c'est le sombre
aboutissement de la fornication
[Musique]
la victoire revient donc à la chasteté
devant le mariage
seule la débauche est à proscrire
s'adressant à ses disciples martin
conclu
que les sages centaines d'ascètes
distinction le mariage est permis la
virginité dans va la gloire et la
fornication et voué au châtiment
sauf si elle est purgée par la pénitence
les pousses du gouverneur avis siens
souhaité disposer d'un médicament
miracle afin de soigner diverses
maladies
la dame versa de l'huile dans une fiole
l'objet avait la forme d'un petit
récipient au ventre rond et ollon goulot
affiné si bien que lorsqu'on ans
remplissait la panse il restait de l'air
dans le col puis elle expédie cette
fiole à saint martin pour qu'il la
bénisse dès qu'il la réceptionne martin
béni la petite bouteille alors lui il se
met à bouillir se multiplient de façon
surnaturel et déborde du goulot même une
fois réexpédier à la dame
la fiole miraculeuse continué d'enfler
le prêtre a testé que par l'effet de la
bénédiction de martin il avait vu lui le
gonfler jusqu'à ce que l'excès en
déborde et se répandent au dehors
aujourd'hui encore selon l'aveu du
prêtre il n'y a pas la place de mettre
un bouchon sur cette ampoule de verre
le miracle de la bouteille inépuisable
appartient au légendaire français et se
présentent aussi ailleurs avec d'autres
personnages par exemple une chronique
médiévale rapporte que l'évêque rémy
aurait remis au roi clovis avant son
départ en guerre une curieuse bouteille
de vin comme il l'avait fait par le
passé
le saint homme lui donna avat que l'on
appelle en général une bouteille remplie
davin qu'il avait béni et il lui
recommanda comme naguère de s'avancer au
combat aussi longtemps que pour lui même
et pour ceux des siens à qui il voudrait
océan données ne manquerait le vin de
cette bouteille alors leurs ouailles
bois puis plusieurs des siens
et pourtant le vase ne souffre pas d'un
manque de vin toujours
il s'agit d'un récipient consacrée par
un évêque martin ou rennie qui contient
un liquide inépuisable huile ou 20 telle
est la source du saint graal dans
laquelle puisera plus tard chrétien de
troyes
[Musique]
l'origine de la légende et celtique on
peut faire le lien avec le chaudron
mythologique de gars des strips daté du
1er siècle et avec le chaudron funéraire
de la princesse de vix daté du 5e siècle
avant notre ère au fil des siècles
payen puis chrétien c'est le même thème
du récipient de vie
[Musique]
dans quelle mesure le paganisme des
anciens druide préfigure-t-il le
christianisme naissant de l'europe le
cas de saint martin est ici emblématique
[Musique]
plusieurs indices inclinent à penser que
l'apôtre de la gaule a en effet hérité
de main attributs du dieu gaulois kern
une hausse saint martin fait pacte de
puissance sur le monde grâce à la prière
c'est sa prière qui dompte les animaux
repousse le feu guérit les malades ou
ressuscite les morts
en tant que maître des animaux martin
domine notamment les serpents sur la
loire un serpent approchait de la rive
où se tenait la baie et ses disciples
martin dit aurait-il au nom du seigneur
je t'ordonne de faire demi-tour à
l'instant le serpent obéi et s'éloigne
des actes de martin s'apparente à
d'anciennes pratiques médicales un
esclave avait été piquée par un serpent
alors martin fit un massage
thérapeutique sur la plaie infectée et
le venin en fut chassé vous voyez toutes
les veines avec la peau enflé et les
organes distendu comme une autre de sa
main tendue
masson tout le membre du garçon martha
fixe à son doigt devant la petite plaie
ou la bête avait à fuser son venin alors
miracle vous dis-je
nous vîmes le venin excité de toutes
parts coulé vers le doigt de martin puis
par le trou de sécu de la blessure
le poison s'entasser avec le sang le
garçon se releva sains et saufs
le corps du sein représente parfois des
caractéristiques inattendue
[Musique]
ainsi du crâne de martin montait une
sorte de chevelure de feu
ce jour là elle lui a fait
extraordinaire que je vais dire comme
l'évêque suivant le rite bénissait
l'hôtel nous vîmes jaillir de sa tête un
globe de feu qui s'étendit vers le haut
à tel point que la flamme prolongeait sa
chevelure déjà longue
et son bras droit s'illuminait de
pourpre comme s'il portait un bracelet
de pierres précieuses
l'ancien préfet harbour atteste avoir vu
la main de martin offrant le sacrifice
comme revêtu des plus nobles j'aime
briller d'un éclat de poupe et à chaque
mouvement de la main droite avoir
entendu le cliquetis des gemmes qui
s'entrechoquaient si l'on résume
plusieurs traits de saint martin que
voit-on
il passe une grande partie de sa vie en
prière il porte une chevelure de feu qui
se prolonge en hauteur il porte à la
main droite un bracelet de gênes il vit
dans la nature
et comment nos animaux notamment
on le voit agir de sa main sur les
serpents
sur le buzz de gains des strips et
graver une image du dieu kern une hausse
or que fait-il car nous nous c'est assis
en tailleur comme en prière il porte une
ramure de serre en guise de haute coiffe
il tient un torque dans sa main droite
et un serpent dans sa main gauche et il
est entouré d'une cour d'animaux tel un
roi des forêts les principaux attributs
de saint martin sont déjà présents chez
le dieu kern une hausse
c'est un héros en prière il a le crâne
surélevé ramure ou chevelure de feu sa
main droite
or un cercle tork ou bracelets de gemmes
il domine le serpent il est le roi de la
nature et commandent aux animaux
le dieu sylvestre des gaulois préfigure
en partie le plus grand sein de
l'occident chrétien
d'où vient martin
d'après son biographe sulpice sévère
martin serait originaire de pannonie
[Musique]
martin était donc originaires de savaria
en pannonie de prime abord ce n'est pas
exclu mais faut-il accorder crédit à
cette affirmation car la pannonie aurait
l'insigne honneur d'être aussi le pays
d'origine des francs si l'on consulte
les sources antiques notamment grégoire
de tours
la tribu de clovis serait elle aussi
venue de pannonie beaucoup rapporte en
effet qu'il serait venu de pannonie or
l'archéologie dément totalement cette
affirmation
les francs était en réalité issues des
bords nordique du rhin et de la meuse
ils ne proviennent donc pas de panneau
ni sur cet indice il pourrait en être de
même pour martin ce n'est sans doute pas
un hasard si un même tropisme oriente
vers le nom de pannonie est le plus
grand sein de france et la tribu
fondatrice et eponine de la france
l'essentiel ici n'est peut-être pas le
lieu géographique de la pannonie mais le
nom même de pannonie dans mon
documentaire les premiers rois francs
j'ai proposé une hypothèse concernant
l'origine légendaire des francs qui vaut
aussi pour saint martin en langue
gauloise paint in us était le nom d'un
dieu qui signifiait le mont sacré la
langue gauloise est un facteur
primordial car les biographes de martin
et de clovis à savoir sulpice sévère et
grégoire de tours sont tous deux des
gaulois
obéit sont inconsciemment à un tropisme
celtique
c'est par une consonance fortuite entre
paint in us le mont sacré et pannonia la
pannonie que les premiers auteurs de la
gaule sulpice et grégoire ont situé sur
les rives du danube l'origine des francs
et l'origine de saint martin
alors qu'en est-il de martin l'homme ce
grand mystique ce bâtisseur d'abbaye
dont l'existence ne fait pas de doute
était peut-être un homme de même origine
ethnique que ceux auxquels il
s'adressait ce qui ferait de martin un
gaulois
d'ailleurs on imagine mal un prêtre ne
maîtrisant pas la langue gauloise
inspirer confiance aux autochtones et
évangéliser la gaule rural or c'est
précisément dans les campagnes et non
dans les villes que saint martin était
vraiment populaire
martin présente des similitudes
évidentes avec le célèbre merlin de la
geste arthurienne le sein de la gaule et
l'enchanteur de la bretagne fréquentent
le même jour deux lieux sauvages et ils
apparaissent comme les maîtres des
forces naturelles homme des bois fou au
prophète tous deux fui la frivolité
tumultueuse des villes pour la mystique
quiétude des campagnes le nom gallois de
merlin et murs dean la consonance entre
martin merlin est mûr dean n'est sans
doute pas fortuite
l'étymologie est probablement celtique
l'étymologie de murs dean ou de merlin
est incertaine
selon les auteurs son nom dériverait
soit de la mer soit du merle mes murs
dean et merlin sont des noms à tester
seulement au moyen-âge tandis que le nom
originel de martin martinus remonte au
4e siècle martinus dérive peut-être des
racines gauloises maros grand et ténot
feu chaleur
d'un point de vue métaphysique toute vie
rayonnant de chaleur et toute mort est
en froid de la vie apparaît comme source
de chaleur
le nom de martin ferait donc allusion au
grand feu au feu de vie l'étymologie du
nom de martin analysée sous un angle
légendaire n'enlève toutefois rien à
l'existence réelle du sein lors de son
baptême ou plus tard lors de son entrée
dans les ordres
l'homme a pu se choisir le nom de martin
en référence à des éléments issus de
l'ancienne religion ethnique
[Musique]
on comprendrait mieux la défiance du
clergé urbain à l'égard de cette
réminiscence de riddick mais aussi
l'adhésion populaire des terroirs
enracinée
tandis qu'il saute
novak hand à 50 kilomètres en aval de
tours martin trépasse le 8 novembre
397 il a 80 ans
l'église fixe toutefois sa fête la saint
martin non pas le jour de sa mort mais
trois jours plus tard à ses funérailles
le 11 novembre mort de mort naturelle
marta est le premier saint mont martyrs
lors du transfert de sa dépouille de
quend à tour
des témoins ont rapporté qu'au passage
de la barque mortuaire les rives de la
loire c'était coloré de fleurs de là
vient que lorsque le temps se radoucit
en automne on parle d t de la saint
martin les funérailles fleuri de martin
nous rappelle aussi le lien étroit entre
morts et végétation au moins de novembre
de nos jours encore à la période de la
toussaint
la coutume veut que l'on aille fleurir
les tombes de nos proches
à la fin de l'année les cimetières se
couvrent incident éclate en pétales ses
moeurs toute chrétienne remonte en fait
à la gaule païenne la toussaint
l'une des quatre messes d'obligations du
catholicisme est une fête directement
inspiré de ce hameau nyos on trouve
trace de la fête de saint magne aux dans
le calendrier de colis ni daté du
deuxième siècle de notre ère
déjà au temps des druides cette période
de l'année était consacrée au défunt la
croyance évolué mais les rites populaire
reste
alors que l'âme de saint martin gagne le
ciel dans le vaste monde
la chrétienté naissante poursuit sa
fulgurante percée en 397 saint jérôme à
50 ans installé à jérusalem
il s'attelle à traduire la bible en
latin qui deviendra la vulgate
saint-augustin à 43 ans passés du
paganisme au christianisme
ce grand théologien du maghreb sera l'un
des principaux pères de l'église et
saint patrick qui n'est encore qu'un
adolescent la providence le réserve pour
l'évangélisation prochaine de l'irlande
de tous les points cardinaux se lève la
chrétienté dont la lente germination va
porter l'europe vers son destin
[Musique]
saint martin a jeté les bases de la
civilisation chrétienne en occident sans
lui on ne saurait expliquer le baptême
de clovis source mystique de la france
et tremplin identitaire de l'europe
martin a fasciné ses contemporains sa
charité a converti les païens des
campagnes sa puissance vertus lui a
permis d'accomplir des miracles de
ressuscité des morts et de dominer
nature et éléments
la gaule lui doit ses premiers
monastères et son hagiographie par
sulpice sévère est le premier monument
de la littérature française
la mémoire de l'europe occidentale et
particulièrement de la france repose en
partie sur le grand oeuvre de saint
martin
saint-martin témoigna d'une vision de
l'apocalypse
il en fit le récit détaillé à son
disciple galles qu'il a ensuite rapporté
à sulpice il existe plusieurs apocalypse
la plus célèbre est celle de saint-jean
qui peut servir à compléter et à
éclairer celle de saint martin
notre époque annonce l'essor imminent
des nouvelles technologies intelligence
artificielle robotique mano technologie
android
hologram
[Musique]
grâce à cette connaissance pratique
l'homme atteindra bientôt des
performances sur humaine tant physique
que mentale comme une démultiplication
de lui même mais ce merveilleux projet
sera-t-il mise au service du bien et de
l'équité ou du mal et de l'arbitraire
[Musique]
d'après des prophéties à la fin du monde
naîtra une créature monstrueuse
l'antéchrist
personnage individuel ou collectif ce
fils de satan sera la représentation du
mensonge et du péché
expert dans l'art de façonner des
prodiges
c'est un mauvais escient qu'il s'en
servira pour séduire et capter les
foules naïve
mais son véritable dessin est ailleurs
sa maîtrise des forces naturelles lui
permettra toutes les audaces
il jouera avec les climats du monde et
répandre à la terreur parmi les nations
[Musique]
l'antéchrist étendra son empire d'abord
sur lorient d'après saint martin il
établira sa capitale à jérusalem
jérusalem où il reconstruire à l'ancien
temple de salomon et il imposera à ces
sujets la loi judaïque en occident
dominera un empereur du nom de néron à
la tête d'une coalition de dix royaume
durant cette sombre période
le christianisme sera doublement
persécutés et par l'idolâtrie de néron
et par l'antéchrist plus pernicieux qui
cherchera à usurper la place du christ
d'ailleurs un jour que nous
l'interrogions soit la fin des temps
martin nous dit que nero est
l'antéchrist viendront d'abord néron
côté occidental après avoir soumis dit
roy se fera empereur puis usant de
persécution il fera par la force
adoré les idoles païennes quant à
l'antéchrist il prendra d'abord le
pouvoir en orient qui aura alors pour
siège capitale du royaume jérusalem il
en restera et la ville et le temple il
forcera par des persécutions à renier la
divinité du christ affirmant que c'est
lui et le christ et leur donnera à tous
la circoncision selon la loi
l'antéchrist c'est dur à des juifs
influent est versée dans les passages
les plus contestés du talmud
envoûtés par de fausses promesses main
juifs voudront voir dans cette créature
démoniaque leur propre messi
[Musique]
un conflit se lèvera entre les deux
maîtres du monde
[Musique]
l'antéchrist trion fera de miron et
soumettra à sa totale autorités presque
tous les peuples de la planète
l'oligarchie cosmopolite composée de
juifs et de gens de toutes origines se
réunira à jérusalem cette gouvernance
mondiale aura pris le contrôle de la
finance des médias des ministères des
tribunaux des lois des armées sous le
feu dassieu prétexte de la paix du monde
jerusalem prononcera la déchéance des
nations et le fichage de toute
l'humanité par leur aveugle obéissance
les masses servent participeront à leur
propre effaceront une société avilit
émietté et malade est évidemment plus
facile à réduire en esclavage qu'une
société saine et homogène
les adorateurs de l'antéchrist porteront
sur eux une marque distinctive
cette reconnaissance biométrique
deviendra obligatoire peut être un
tatouage sur la peau ou une puce
électronique dans la chair sous le joug
de cette tyrannie uniformisatrice la
marque de la bête signera le renoncement
de l'homme à lui-même ou la fin de
l'histoire
certains de ces morts-vivants se
complèteront dans la consommation à vide
des plaisirs terrestres
toujours dans la dépendance et jamais
satisfait
les masses égarés se résigneront à la
misère et l oubli
les sentiments supérieur tel le salut de
notre âme la fidélité à notre patrie ou
la vraie charité n'auront plus droit de
cité tous ceux qui refuseront de
recevoir la marque de la bête seront
persécutés
banny ruine et emprisonnés
[Musique]
devenus des dissidents puis des rebelles
les hommes libres trouveront le salut
dans la fuite
là où l'on n'échappera encore au
contrôle de la police mondiale loin des
mégapoles occupé par la gouvernance des
communautés enraciné se développeront en
autarcie dans les provinces chacune sera
forte de son identité culturelle et de
son génie propre source des peuples en
devenir
[Musique]
et la vertu d'espérance portera ses
fruits
car c'est au sein de cette assemblée
d'hommes libres que naîtra le sauveur
des nations a semblé se dit ecclesia en
grec c'est à dire églises dans les
textes
cette église libre est symbolisé par une
femme qui s'enfuit au désert elle aura
mis au monde un fils héroïques qui sera
protégé par dieu
c'est le retour du christ dont on sait
selon ses propres dires qu'il vient
apporter aux hommes nous la paix mais le
glaive or la femme met au monde un
enfant mal celui qui doit amener toutes
les nations avec un centre de fer et son
enfant suite enlevez jusqu'au près de
dieu et de son trône tandis que la femme
s'enfuyait toits déserts où dieu lui
aménager un refuge pour qu'elles soient
nourris
mille deux cent soixante jours
le règne de l'antéchrist durerait trois
ans et demi chiffre symbolique puisqu'il
correspond à la durée de la vie publique
de jésus dont il est l'ennemi
enfin viendra l'ultime bataille qui doit
décider du sort du monde en guerre
contre la gouvernance mondiale de
jérusalem bientôt les communautés libres
et des du christ lanceront une violente
contre attaque
ce sera le retour de l'histoire du ciel
dieu envers à la foudre sur l' empire du
mal
le trio infernal satan l'antéchrist et
la bête vaincu finiront oglou tease à
jamais dans un lac volcanique
les mails ont écoulé satan relâché de sa
prison sans nuire à séduire les nations
des quatre coins de la terre gog et
magog et les rassembler pour la guerre
aussi nombreux que le sable de la mer
ils montèrent sur toute l'étendue du
pays puis investir le camp des saints la
cité bien aimé mais un feu descendu du
ciel et les dévs aura alors le diable
leur séducteur fut jetée dans les temps
de feu et de soufre et rejoignant la
bête et le faux prophète et leur
supplice durera jour et nuit pour les
siècles des siècles
tron aura enfin la sainte trinité père
fils et saint-esprit
les morts seront jugés et les nations
recevront selon leur mérite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'ancien monde mourra il faut enfin que
l'antéchrist face périr néron lui même
et qu'il réduit ainsi en son pouvoir le
monde entier tous les peuples
jusqu'à ce que la venue du christ écrase
l'api
la cité céleste aura vaincu la jérusalem
terrestre
les valeurs chrétiennes d'harmonie et de
pureté l'emporteront sur le chaos et le
mal dans le vaste monde
l'innocence pourra renaître l'amour plus
fort que la matière redonnera vie aux
anciens peuple fidèle à l'enseignement
de saint martin un nouveau clovis
ressuscite fois la civilisation de
l'incarnation dieu pour les siècles des
siècles
[Musique]
oh